Ich bin die Töne der Ärztin auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, natürlich Frau Doktor.
Ok, ich werde zuerst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Dann, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Helmut Schneider.
Helmut Schneider?
Helmut Schneider, ja.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Vornamen bestabieren?
H, E, L, M, U, T
M, U, T, ok.
S, H, E, I, D, I, R
D, I, R, ok. Schneider.
Schneider.
Schneider, die.
Hörschneider.
Mit D oder mit T?
Mit Nachnamen oder?
Nachnamen.
M, D, R.
R, mit D, ok. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 51 Jahre alt.
51, ok. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich 3. Juli 1973.
73, ok. Und wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin 1 Meter 70.
Ok. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
81 Kilogramm.
80?
Ja.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Meine Hausärztin heißt Frau Müller.
Frau Müller.
Danke schön, Herr.
Ja, Herr, ja.
Danke schön, Herr Schneider, für diese Informationen.
Und was für Sie heute zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe eine starke Bauchschmerzen.
Bauchschmerzen. Wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Meine Schmerzen sind im Oberbauch.
Oberbauchschmerzen.
Ja.
Ok. Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Eigentlich habe ich diese Schmerzen seit zwei Wochen.
Aber seit zwei Tagen sind sie schlimmer geworden.
Schlimmer.
Ja.
Ok. Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei ein sehr lafter 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht?
Das ist ungefähr 7.
7. Könnten Sie das Gespräch bis zum Ende aushalten?
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis zum Ende das Gespräch aushalten?
Oder könnten Sie jetzt eine Schmerzmittel?
Wie lange dauert das Aufnahmegespräch?
Es dauert ca. 15 Minuten.
Ok. Ich kann aushalten.
Ok. Sind Ihre Schmerzen irgendeine Körperteile aus?
Nein. Sie sind nicht irgendeine Körperteile aus.
Ok. Sie haben Oberbauchschmerzen.
Ja.
Wie lange dauert das?
Ganz obere.
Ja.
Ok. Haben Sie einige begleitende Schmerzen?
Zum Beispiel haben Sie Überleuchtung oder Erbrechen?
Ja. Ich hatte zweimal Erbrechen.
Zweimal Erbrechen. Wie sah diese Erbrechen aus?
Sie sahen einen Kaffeesatz.
Kaffeesatz.
Ja.
Ok. Herr Schneider, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ja. Ich habe gestern bemerkt, dass mein Stuhl braun ist.
Sie haben seit gestern braun Stuhl.
Ja.
Richtig?
Ja. Es ist wie Tee.
Ok. Als Kaffeesatz.
Ja.
Ok. Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ok.
Sind Sie mitgekommen?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ok.
Deswegen diese Schmerzen.
Ich bin nicht ganz erstaunt.
Aber normalerweise habe ich keine Müdigkeit.
Könnten Sie sich nicht bemerken?
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind diese Schmerzen drückend, brennend oder dumpf?
Die Schmerzen sind dumpf.
Ok. Denken Sie, es gibt einen Auslöser für die Schmerzen.
Wie haben diese Schmerzen begonnen?
Ich habe bemerkt, dass meine Schmerzen immer schlimmer geworden sind.
Ok. Sind die Schmerzen guterförmig?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe nicht die Schmerzen immer ganz oberpauch.
Ok. Hatten Sie diese Schmerzen früher schon einmal begonnen?
Ich habe diese Schmerzen früher nicht gehabt.
Ok. Sie haben diese Schmerzen seit zwei Wochen.
Ja.
Aber seit zwei Tagen sind sie immer schlimmer geworden.
Ok. Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber?
Ja, ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich jetzt ein bisschen fieberisch.
Sie haben recht. Können Sie das Fieber messen?
Ja, natürlich.
Haben Sie Schüttlerfrüße?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nachschweiß? Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Ok. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich ab- oder zugenommen?
Ich habe zwei Kilo Zunäme zugenommen, ja.
Wie lange?
Seit zwei Wochen.
Seit zwei Wochen haben Sie zwei Kilogramm zugenommen?
Ja.
Zugenommen. Ok.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen? Ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen, Doktor.
Ok. Haben Sie Brüste?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ok. Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstolpen oder Herzklofen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Hüste?
Atemnot, Hüste, nein.
Ok. Herr Schneider, ich möchte dieses Gespräch jetzt unterbrechen.
Warum?
Ich möchte Ihre Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Ich werde Ihren Blutdruck, Sauerstoff, Sättigung, Fieber, Atemfrequenz und Puls kontrollieren.
Und ich werde ein EKG schreiben.
Dann nehme ich einen Blutabnehmen.
Gibt es einen Notfall, Frau Doktor? Warum schreiben Sie einen EKG? Ich habe keine Herzprobleme.
Ok. Aber das ist eine routinelle Maßnahme.
Wenn eine Patientin eine Bauchschmerzen hat, möchten wir einen EKG schreiben.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Aber ich möchte, Sie haben keine gefährliche Situation.
Ok. Ich verstehe kein Licht, aber ok.
Ok. Weiterentzüglichen. Wir werden diese Untersuchungen weitergeben.
Ok.
Ok. Dann ...
Ich bin weiter.
Haben Sie Alergien? Oder eine Fertigkeitsmischung?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergien.
Ok. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise gut, aber seit zwei Wochen habe ich kaum Appetit und habe eine Schmerzen.
Ok. Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise gut, aber deswegen diese Beschwerden. Schlafen ist nicht gut.
Ok. Haben Sie Zotibrennen, Blechungen oder Sauerstoff?
Ich habe keine Bemerkung.
Ok. Fühlen Sie sich voll und aufgebläht?
Nein, ich habe keine Beschwerden.
Ok. Hören Sie sich an, haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen? Zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, ich habe Bluthochdruck seit 10 Jahren.
Ok. Noch etwas?
Ich habe Rheumatoid Arthritis seit 12 Jahren.
12 Jahren. Ok. Haben Sie andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe Rückenschmerzen und vor fünf Jahren hatte ich eine Brustitis.
Haben Sie Probleme oder Atemnot?
Nein, jetzt nicht. Aber vor zwei Jahren habe ich zwei Wochen im Krankenhaus geblieben.
Zwei Wochen. Ok.
Bei mir wurde eine Medikamentos-Tedau behandelt.
Ok.
Jetzt bin ich gut. Danke, Doktor.
Ok. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme Kapto-Pril 25 mg dreimal täglich.
Und ich nehme Prädnisolon 15 mg einmal täglich morgens.
50 mg, ok. Morgens.
15 mg. Nicht 50. 15. 15.
15 mg. Ok.
Und ich nehme Diplophenak 50 mg dreimal täglich ein.
Dreimal? Ok. Noch etwas?
Das war.
Das war. Ok. Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich hatte zweimal Operation.
Welche Operation haben Sie gemacht?
Bei mir wurde eine Apendektomitduschgefürt.
Wo war diese Operation?
Ich war im Altefon in Levenia.
Ok. Asen.
Noch etwas? Die anderen Operationen?
Ja, ich hatte eine Crossbanddraises.
Bei mir wurde eine Operationduschgefürt.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung welche Operation. Wie heißt das?
Ok. Haben Sie einige Fertleinsen?
Welche Beine?
Rechte Beine.
Ok. Wo war diese Operation?
Vor Senjaren.
Ok. Herr Schneider, rauen Sie?
Ja, leider.
Seit wann rauen Sie?
Seit 20 Jahren rauche ich 30 Zigaretten täglich.
Ja, ein bisschen viel.
Ja, leider.
Und trinken Sie auch Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke eine Flasche jeden Tag.
Und zwei Glas Wein pro Woche.
Ok. Hatten Sie schon einmal Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich habe keine Erfahrung mit Drogen.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, Doktor. Ich möchte regelmäßig Sport treiben, aber ich habe keine Zeit.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin LKW-Fahrer.
Ok. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei Tochter.
Sind Ihre Tochter gesund?
Ja, ja.
Sind Sie vollständig geübt?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geübt.
Ok. Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind LKW-Fahrer.
Ich möchte fragen, waren Sie letztes Mal im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, Doktor. Meine Arbeit ist immer in Deutschland.
Ok. Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Bei dem Vater oder der Mutter?
Mein Vater ist mit 85 Jahren an Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Es tut mir sehr leid. Und?
Meine Mutter lebt jetzt und sie ist gesund. Aber sie hatte einen Myokardinfarkt.
Ja, sie hatte auch einen Myokardinfarkt.
Ja, ja.
Ok. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, sie ist gesund.
Ok. Herr Schneider, ich habe alle meine wichtigen Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja Doktor, was habe ich? Ich habe viel Angst. Sie haben unsere Gespräche unterbrochen.
Ich habe viel Angst. Was habe ich?
Herr Schneider, Sie können viele Fragen haben. Deshalb kann ich Ihnen leider noch keine Antwort geben.
Aber um eine deutsche Diagnose zu stellen, müssen wir noch einige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich vermute, Sie haben ein Verdauungssystemprobleme. Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen genauer sagen.
Jetzt möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen. Ich werde Ihre Beschwerden mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Dann warte ich alle Ergebnisse und ich werde zurückkommen und Sie informieren.
Ok, danke. Ich warte auf Sie.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich. Bitte schön.
Ok, der Patient heißt Helmut Schneider. Er ist 51 Jahre alt, 1,70 Meter groß und wiegt 81 Kilogramm.
Herr Schneider ist heute bei uns und wir sind zwei Wochen lang bei ihm.
Er hat seit gestern zwei Mal Melena und Hematomasis.
Er hat eine Gewichtverlust von zwei Wochen.
Gewichtverlust oder Gewichtszunahme?
Ja, genau.
Ok, Gewichtszunahme.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 7 von 10. Ich habe gefragt, ob Sie eine Schmerzmittel brauchen.
Aber Sie haben verneint.
Während unseres Gesprächs habe ich die Schmerzmittel überprüft und eine EKG geschrieben.
Ich habe gedacht, der Patient habe eine obergasrointestinale Blutung. Deshalb möchte ich diese Parameter überprüfen.
Der Patient klagt über Schmerzbedingte Appetitlosigkeit und Insomnie.
Der Patient leidet seit Jahren an arteriale Hypertonie.
Hat er Fieber?
Ja, der Patient hat eine Fiebergefühle.
Aber er hat keine Temperatur.
Er leidet seit zehn Jahren an arteriale Hypertonie und seit zwölf Jahren an rheumatoide Arthritis.
Er hat langsamer Schmerzen.
Der Patient leidet seit zehn Jahren an arteriale Hypertonie und seit zwölf Jahren an rheumatoide Arthritis.
Er leidet seit zehn Jahren an arteriale Hypertonie und seit zwölf Jahren an rheumatoide Arthritis.
In der Familienanamnese wird angegeben, dass sein Vater an einem Myokardialinfarkt verstorben ist.
Seine Mutter hatte einen Myokardialinfarkt, aber sie ist nun gesund.
Er hat eine Schwester, eine gesunde Schwester.
Er leidet seit 20 Jahren an arteriale Hypertonie und seit zwölf Jahren an arteriale Hypertonie und seit zwölf Jahren an rheumatoide Arthritis.
Sie trinkt ein Fleischbier jeden Tag und er trinkt zwei Gläser Wein pro Woche.
Die Drogenkonstruktion wurde entfernt und er trägt keinen Sport.
Er ist LKW-Fahrer, arbeitet als LKW-Fahrer und ist verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Kinder,
hat keine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit, ist vollständig giftig und reist an Amneseva unaufhängig.
Die Anamnistischen angaben dort in Amn e. H. stand, eine obere Gastrointestinale blüht hin.
Als differential Diagnosen kamen, war der Fagus, war es, oder?
Ja, und Magenkarsen oder Urkos, oder?
Ja, der Patienten habe Melena, der Patienten habe Hematomasis, das ist eine wichtigste Seite,
das ist eine wichtigste Seite, und er habe auch Melena, und er habe epigastrische Schmerzen, diese.
Und er habe einige Risikofaktoren, Nikotin und Alkohol, Abussus.
Und noch etwas?
Sie haben, er benutzt dreimal täglich die Klopfenak, seit langem, das ist eine Risikofaktor.
Seit langem, genau.
Ohne?
Ohne Magenschutz.
Genau.
Und er ist LKW-Fahrer von Beruf, ich glaube er hat viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ja, viel Stress, und ich denke sie haben nicht eine regelmäßige Ernährungsgewohnheit.
Das kann einige, das andere Risikofaktor.
Ok, also Sie haben schon ein EKG geschrieben, also kommt ein Myokardinfarkt als Diffensierdiagnose bei diesem Patienten?
Ja, natürlich.
Und warum?
Ein Myokardinfarkt kann beim Obawa-Schmerzen vorliegen.
Deshalb möchte ich eine.
Hat der Patient auch irgendwelche anderen Risikofaktoren?
Ja, sie haben Arteriellehypertension seit zehn Jahren.
Und er, Noxon-Anamnes ist ein Risikofaktor für sie.
Noch etwas?
Die Familienanamnes, sie hat eine familiäre Disposition.
Ok, also Sie haben eine Verdachtdiagnose, jetzt was machen Sie?
Um Ihre Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen?
Ja, die Abklärung der Beschwerden sollte durchgeführt werden.
So als würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich würde ganz Oberbauch palpieren und Lunge, Bauch und Herz auskultieren.
Und ich würde den Allgemeinen Zustand der Patienten beurteilen.
Dann werde ich natürlich, ich habe gemacht, aber während der Untersuchung würde ich wiederholen,
Vitalparameter kontrollieren und ich möchte diese Patienten engmaschig beobachten.
Deshalb würde ich einen Monitor beobachten.
Ja, Monitorisation oder Anchilisieren.
Worauf achten Sie bei der Inspektion?
Bei der Inspektion erwarte ich beim Patienten Residuärtermall am Allgemeinen Zustand.
Also seit zwei Wochen hat er eine Blutung?
Ja, deshalb hat er Blasehaut und Blasekongestiva.
Palo, wir können sagen, als Fachbegriff.
Er hat blaue Lippen und blaue Finger.
Also blaue Lippen und blaue Finger, das ist eine Sianose.
Der Patient hat keine Atemnot.
Ok, dann was machen Sie jetzt für operativdiagnostische Methoden?
Zuerst würde ich einen Röntgenaufdarm erlassen.
Warum?
Ich möchte eine Perforation ausschließen.
Und danach würde ich eine Abdomen-Sonographie durchführen.
Und natürlich Abdomen-Sonographie durchführen.
Warum machen Sie eine Abdomen-Sonographie?
Was erwartet Sie?
Ich kann die innere Organe beurteilen.
Welche Organe meinen Sie?
Besonders Magen oder Darm.
Oberbauchschmerzen, was denken Sie an?
Als Differenz der Diagnose.
Welche Krankheit kommt auch als Differenz der Diagnose?
Pankreatitis kommt auch als Differenz der Diagnose.
Bei der Ultrasonographie, was erwarten Sie?
Bei einer Pankreatitis, ich meine.
Bei einer Pankreatitis, eine große Egalität in der Pankrease. Nein.
Ich weiß nicht, ich gehe nicht weiter.
Okay, machen Sie weiter.
Und gegebenenfalls werde ich ein CT-Abdomen veranlassen.
Aber für diesen Fall ist eine Osephago-Gastrodiodynoskopie wichtig.
Deshalb würde ich zuerst ein gastroentrologisches Konzept anfordern.
Oder vorbereiten.
Warum?
Warum veranlassen Sie eine ÖGD bei diesen Patienten?
Was erwarten Sie und was machen Sie bei dieser Untersuchung?
Ich meine ÖGD.
ÖGD ist eine diagnostische und außerdem eine Behandlungsverschmutzung.
Deshalb können wir mit Hilfe der ÖGD die Hand behandeln.
Wir können alle Organe des Osephagos und der Diodon beurteilen.
Wir können die Blutunggefäße finden und mit ÖGD behandeln.
Während der Untersuchung können wir auch eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Sie haben eine Verdachtdiagnose und Sie haben schon die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigt.
Welche Therapiemöglichkeiten haben wir bei diesen Patienten?
Das ist eine akute Situation.
Zuerst werde ich die symptomatische Therapie planen.
Ich würde einen Zugang legen und eine ausreichende Flüssigkeit veranlassen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten mit Protonpumpe beginnen.
Oder mit Zugang veranlassen.
Dann ...
Wie kann ich das sagen?
Ja.
Notfallmäßige Therapien sind sehr wichtig.
Das habe ich schon gesagt.
Während der ÖGD müssen wir die Blutung speisen.
Ja.
Und Flüssigkeit zuvor.
Das habe ich schon gesagt.
Das ist gut.
Protonpumpe ist auch sehr wichtig.
Und dann ...
Was würden Sie machen?
Ja.
Falls wir die Patienten nicht behandeln, können wir eine Operation machen.
Operation.
Wenn es eine Ulcosypathie gibt, was würden Sie als Therapie anordnen?
Okay.
Die Behandlung von Ulcosypathie verschreibe ich in einigen Medikamenten.
Zuerst Protonpumpe HEMA ist wichtig.
Und eine Antibioterapie.
Dann können wir mit Methanidazol oder Amoxicillin und Chloridstremis beginnen.
Und ...
Helikopter Pylori Eradikation.
Eradikation.
Die ÖGD oder die Gelbeprobe kann auch Helikopter Pylori sein.
Dann können wir eine Eradikation-Therapie beginnen.
Mit diesem Antibiotikum.
Und ich empfehle der Patienten Nikotin und Alkoholkaranz.
Auch der Patient muss ...
Der Patient muss ...
... NCA ...
... R ...
... benutzen. Nein.
Der Patient ...
... aufgehört. Nein.
Also regelmäßige Einnahme von Magenschutz ist sehr wichtig bei diesen Patienten. Genau.
Und ich glaube wir haben schon vergessen über Laboruntersuchungen.
Sprechen Frau Doktor, welche Laboruntersuchungen würden Sie kontrollieren? Ja.
Ja, ich werde ...
Ich habe Blut ...
Ich habe während der DAG-Spray Blut abgenommen.
Und ich würde ...
Und ich habe ...
... zuerst ...
... ein großes Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter und Herzensüme und Geröhnungsparameter.
Und ...
... Blutgruppe ...
... Sättigung und ...
... Nierenwerte und Lebewerte kontrolliert.
Kontrolliert. Okay.
Was kann ich sagen?
Ich würde ...
Ich habe ...
... Herzensüme ...
... veranlassen.
Herzensüme anfordern.
Und ...
... ein Meokartinfarkt auszuschließen.
Und ich habe auch ...
... Geröhnungsparameter und Blutgruppe-Sättigung ...
... veranlassen.
Und ...
... wenn der Patient ...
... falls der Patient ...
... Blut ...
... brachen ...
... möchte ich ...
... möchte ich für diese Situation vorbereiten.
Okay.
Herr Chefarzt, sind Sie da?